and mike will make his ninth start of
the season hud yes mike miner is coming
off his best outing of the year without
a doubt everything was working for him
that era after tonight should be well
under five
and now it is candelario
check swing he went
salvi picks it up throws to first
there's a strikeout a one two three
inning for
lefty mike miner and jose arena is
making his ninth start of the season
it's his first career start like shep
said against the royals
will be his 28th different major league
team that he has started against and
after tonight the only teams he hasn't
faced are his former team miami and the
toronto blue jays here's carlos santana
second pitch on the ground nice play by
miguel cabrera with the backhand
andrew benintendi impressively the other
way he does that a lot he's going to dig
for two haas's throw is in time to nail
him he got greedy and hoss threw him out
boy it's usually eric haas throwing guys
out from behind the plate at second base
this time he does it from left field his
first career assists and it ends the
kansas city first
miguel cabrera eric haas and nico
goodrim for the tigers here in the
second the two oda cabrera and he drives
one to deep left center field back it
goes that ball is gone a home run for
miguel cabrera he continues his assault
on the royals at kaufman stadium it's
one nothing tigers every once in a while
miggy shows that swing that powerful
swing that he has this ball was kind of
right in his wheelhouse that's where he
likes it and he didn't miss it
one-nothing tigers in the second two up
two down after the home run by cabrera
now wilson ramos the designated hitter
and he awaits the 3-2 pitch here it is
swinging a miss got him with a fastball
and inning is over one hit one run the
home run by cabrera balls one strike
next pitch
bouncing ball deep short and it gets by
goodrim and on into left field
goodrum
i think he took a little peek no reason
he
got to the ball in good shape just
backhanded he had a lot of time of
course but
got careless
opens the door for jorge solaire the 2-2
wave and a miss and a big strikeout for
arena
goodrem on the turn there it is and the
double play converted for the tigers
we gave you the ground ball rate for
mourinho he got it at a key time here in
the second
now jake rogers here it comes again
and he gets a swing and a miss and
strikes out jake rogers that's his third
of the ball game and he's on for the
first time and detroit has their second
base runner just go grounded to short
his first time up
in there strike three call
miner works his third inning we head to
the bottom of the third
and the royals have runners at first and
third with two down so here's an rbi
spot for carlos santana one nothing
tigers two down bottom of the third we
had bluff to move and the ball gets away
and there goes whit
to second base
it likely will be a pass ball
he does get it through and comes
gutierrez and comes merrifield the
royals take a 2-1 lead he's a premier
rbi guy that's off the end watch out
that bad head's coming flying but look
that bat died a hero no question with
two stakes attached to him that is a
perfect hit with two runners on in
second and third given the royals the
lead that was well done putting runners
at first and third for the tigers here
in the fourth you go good room a chance
to tie it up the o2 to good
on the ground and through the left side
for a base hit an rbi single for nico
goodroom ties it up at two
oh wonder ramos up the middle and a base
hit haas takes a glance taylor comes up
throwing haas is going to try and score
and he is out at the plate
is pretty insistent that he got didn't
get tagged i don't think he tagged him
though first replay inconclusive second
replay
never touched him great job by haas
an rbi single for wilson ramos the
tigers have taken the lead look at him
he says i told you i told you for robbie
grossman his second hit on the night so
he's a base runner he's seven for seven
stealing bases
got him picked off
grossman thinks he's safe the call was
he's out wit good tag did he get it on
him in time
they're going to check it
i don't know i think it's going to still
go the tigers way ah he's out hey we'll
take it
nice job by miners that'll go down as a
pick off
cold strike three
good morning good afternoon and good
night seven strikeouts for minor he
faces the minimum so here's ramos
the o2
got him to swing at a slider in the dirt
struck him out struck out eight tonight
here's the 1-1
swung on hit in the air deep right
center field that's going to carry and
it's going to be off the wall on a
bounce
and salvy jogs into second base
with a leadoff double brian o'hearn has
rounded out twice once into a double
play it's three and two on o'hern and
the pitch is swung on and lined into
right field for a base hit near the line
here's salvi around third
and the throw will come in and be cut
off and ryan o'hearn
ties the game
with a single to right and it's 3-3 in
the sixth michael a taylor i guarantee
you he's looking in you wait for the
mistake and don't miss it he'll make a
mistake he'll leave one in the middle
and that's when you got to be ready for
it this will be the 10th pitch of the
at-bat for taylor
there's a drop baby deep to left
gone
put some barbecue sauce on that baby
11 piss i'm telling you the advantage
goes to the hitter michael a taylor was
setting him up
oh that was nice stay lead 5-3
bases are loaded for the tigers robbie
grossman has himself
a three-hit performance so far
oh he gets away
they've got to play at the plate
and he's out
man you know you got the pitcher
standing there covering the plate like
that look you could slide hard knock the
pitcher down drop the ball
man i don't get that but look the royals
will take that out
fastball barely misses ball four
and they're loaded again
candelario was one for three against
mike miner
in there strike three call
that was his best fastball a four seamer
just let it rip one of the best closures
of our era greg holland matching up with
a future hall of famer in miguel cabrera
swinging a fly ball left field deep
going back benintendi it's over his head
and it's gone a home run
grand slam home run for miguel cabrera
oh he looks into that dugout as he goes
around third they're going crazy and the
tigers dugout the welcoming committee at
home a grand slam home run and the
tigers have taken a 7-5 lead here in the
seventh
7-5 detroit we go to the bottom of
inning number nine and michael fulmer
comes in to pitch for detroit
merrifield has had success against
fulmer
10 for 25 and two home runs right now
all he wants to do is get on base
so both guys knew what was coming ground
ball to short goodra handles it a one
two three ninth for michael fulmer a
massive night for miguel cabrera the
tigers winning streak is at four they
beat the royals 7-5